here's our list of the top five most
anticipated films playing out the 2014
Los Angeles Film Festival number five I
am Big Bird and Caroll Spinney story
directed by Dave lamattina and Chad
Walker a documentary about Caroll
Spinney who has been Sesame Street's Big
Bird and Oscar the Grouch since 1969 at
78 years old he has no intention of
stopping after the inspiring and
educational likes of being Elmo a
puppeteers journey were eager to meet
another artist beneath the iconic
character number for the life and mind
of marc de fries written and directed by
Gabriel London this documentary sits us
down with marc de fries the man who
earned a reputation as the Houdini of
high-security prisons after some
eighteen elaborate escape attempts
sometimes all you need for a successful
documentary is a fascinating subject but
the life and mind of marc de fries also
employs graphic novel like animation in
lieu of standard reenactments number
three man from Rena written and directed
by Dave Boyle a stranger in the
increasingly strange city of San
Francisco Japanese crime novelist a key
is unsure of precisely what role she has
to play in a real-life murder mystery
Boyle's previous films also center
around the lives of japanese-americans
albeit through a comedic lens we're
eager to see this writer director try
his hand at a mystery thriller
number two the two faces of January
written and directed by Hossein Amini
this is the feature-length directorial
debut for me the screenwriter behind the
four feathers and drive a thriller
centered on a con artist his wife and a
stranger who tried to flee a foreign
country after one of them is caught up
in a murder of a police officer the two
faces of January boasts an exciting cast
with Kirsten Dunst Viggo Mortensen and
Luanne Davis himself Oscar Isaac number
one snowpiercer written and directed by
bong joon-ho after threatened cuts and
disheartening delays snowpiercer will
finally be on us screens has the opening
night film of the festival in a future
where a filled global warming experiment
kills off all life on the planet except
for a lucky few that boarded the
snowpiercer a train that travels around
the globe where a class system evolves
the film is a joint production between
South Korea the United States the cast
includes Chris Evans John Hurt til the
swim and bond favorite song kang-ho for
us in the States this is the first time
to see the film has the exciting Korea
natur intended those are our top five
most anticipated films playing at the
2014 Los Angeles Film Festival let us
know what movies you're most excited for
in the comments below keep a tab open on
the movieclips Film Festival channel for
trailers clips and more thanks for
watching